hi there Steve Kaufman and I haven't
done a video for a long long time I've
been busy I I was in Russia where I had
a ball I think I mentioned that I came
back then I went down to California we
had a there was an old-timers hockey
tournament in Santa Rosa went down there
for ten days sampled the wine in the
Sonoma Wine Country lovely part of the
world 26 degrees during the day of 15
degrees in the evening drove back drove
down by amount shots the lake shots and
so forth came back up along the
California coast through the redwood
forests visited with a very good school
boy friend who lives in Portland and
I've been busy now a major event in my
life two weeks ago we introduced what we
call beta languages at Linc we
introduced four languages Polish Dutch
Arabic and Czech and we're going to
introduce one one language a month we
call them beta or unsupported languages
because we're not going to make any
effort to to find content we will add
dictionaries as people ask for them but
if we encounter special problems
we're not promising to be able to
support any specific you know or resolve
any specific issues that are specific to
to a given language so and with that I
started in the Czech I started I guess
it's about two weeks ago and I'm having
a ball
and it's really the first language that
I've started totally from scratch and
linked because in the case of Russian
before we had Russian at link I did get
started I had used the teach yourself
series the colloquial series even bought
an icy mill all of this while waiting
for Russian to get going at link but
with with Czech I'm basically doing all
that link and it's working very well I
feel that I've made more progress in two
weeks
then I can remember having made in any
of the other languages that I started
studying using the established teaching
materials largely thanks to the work of
yard
Yaroslav from the Czech Republic who has
created a ton of content unfortunately
all of these things we have to work out
the bugs I pointed out that the sound
quality on some of his material wasn't
that great he has been researching you
know a microphone he's got audacity he's
improved the sound quality he's
recording some of it it really doesn't
matter but it's fine of course in the
case of three articles that we have on
link that exist in all languages I'm
already familiar with those in English
and Russian so doing them in check out
you know with what the subject matter is
but there's also a lot of other great
stuff there easy stuff there's also some
more difficult content that's been
loaded up by one of our learners from
Brazil who's studying checked so I kind
of vary it with easy stuff more
difficult stuff waiting in the wings I
have the good soldiers fake that I have
an audiobook of but I want to get my
level up before I do it and one thing
that makes the whole process very
enjoyable is the iPad because I go on to
link I listen I read I save words and
phrases I linked them as we say and I do
that rather quickly and once that's done
on the computer from then on I'm
operating on my iPad and so I've got all
kinds of lessons here on my on my I link
app I don't know 30 40 lessons that I've
gone through very quickly read them and
of course while I'm reading them on the
screen the the meaning of the word
flashes up and I can stream the audio so
I understand it but when I listen to it
again I don't understand it if I'm not
really but all of that I can do on the
iPad so I can see all the yellow
highlighted words that I looked up I can
listen to the audio so I can sit in a
comfortable chair I even
have at home an elliptical trainer so I
get on the elliptical trainer i plug my
you know earphones into the ipad because
at this stage in my check without
reading along I don't understand what
they're saying half the time so I'm
doing this and saving more words every
so often I can review my flashcards on
the iPad I can also review them
obviously on the computer next week we
already have in what we call our QA
server like that up on production yet we
have text-to-speech for Czech and polish
and Arabic and Dutch which we didn't
have that's been having it in so when I
really view my flashcards over now or
when I'm reading on the screen I can
click on each word and do a
text-to-speech just to help remind me of
how that word sounds and you know I go
through I save words and phrases I
review them I don't worry about what I
forget I haven't looked at a single
table yet I don't want to know what the
endings in the different cases whatever
are I will get around to doing that
right now I'm just letting it fly I'm
letting the the the sound and the
meaning come over you know wash through
me and gradually picking up more and
more you know certain words are starting
to sound natural you know they use the
word vu pets all the time like actually
Lubitz toy yeah oh yeah yeah nor
whatever there's a lot of expressions
like that that are starting to start to
feel natural and when I've had enough
exposure then I'll go in and perhaps
have a look at some of the grammar but I
have the feeling that in two weeks I
have achieved more in terms of my
comprehension at least while listening
and reading then I have achieved even
when I started up with Portuguese and I
using the teacher cell so I do believe
even though a lot of people say that
it's difficult to start from scratch and
link I'm doing it with check and I feel
very confident and in a year from now I
want to go to Prague and also to Prost
off which is where my parents were born
about a hundred years ago literally a
hundred years ago and and use my check I
think the check will go faster than the
Russian because the Russian help
tremendously in the Czech I mean many of
the constructions I feel as if I'm
hearing Russian because of the way the
language is structured the vocabulary is
surprisingly different there are a lot
of words in Czech that are not related
to words in Russian which really
surprised me of course the problem I
have with Czech is that between all my
other activities I'm trying to get
better at golf now because my wife is
very keen on golf and I've cars got my
business to run and I haven't given up
on Russian I take my daily download from
echo Moskvy and I I do enjoy that
because there I totally understand what
they're talking about and it's
interesting so I got to squeeze the
check in on the other hand I I don't
think my goals are as high for checked
if I can get conversational in Czech
that's fine and whatever I've time I
find for it that'll be fine it may
eventually start to consume me more than
the Russian but it's still kind of a bit
of a backseat to the russian at this
point but i'm excited i'm excited that
the progress that I've made with with
checked in just a couple of weeks and I
know that doll of fuzziness will
gradually start to dissipate and more
and more of the language is gonna start
to start to feel natural so thank you
yarda and just to let you know that i'm
having a ball with my check thank you
for listening bye